what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
know that at the end of the video on how
to kill the juggernaut I tease that
solomon grundy would be the next video
in the series but actually were going to
push him back after this we're going to
do Lobo who's basically DC's version of
Wolverine but because of the fact that
Logan gives us the first in movie
appearance of x-23 which is a momentous
occasion I figured we would celebrate
this incredible moment by talking about
how to kill x-23 so for those of you
guys who were not familiar with the
Laura Kenny as always I'll provide a
brief description of her and her powers
but if you want a full rundown on her
history I have a character explanation
on X 23 here on my channel but I'm also
going to be doing her origin story this
coming weekend so hopefully that will
help you guys to get a good
understanding of what's going on with
her character now the most important
thing to know is that X 23 is basically
a clone that's made from a damaged DNA
sample of Wolverine because of this X 23
has all the same powers as Wolverine
including a regenerative healing factor
heightened senses enhanced reflexes
speed and endurance as well as
retractable boned claws now unlike
Wolverine glass three claws on his hand
X 23 only has two claws on each hand and
a claw in her foot in addition to this
Wolverine has a complete adamantium
skeleton X 23 does not now although she
was initially created for the purpose of
killing Wolverine she would eventually
become part of the x-men and become a
surrogate daughter to Wolverine himself
but due to the extensive and often
brutal training that she received while
she was at the facility as well as the
training she received from will rain
x-23 is an extremely effective
hand-to-hand fighter and has also
received training in explosives and a
wide range of different weaponry now for
many of the same reasons that Wolverine
is hard to kill killing x-23 presents a
great challenge even if you are able to
defeat her in a fight which is unlikely
in and of itself
not only due to her prowess as a fighter
but also due to the fact that she can
become even more dangerous when she is
exposed to a trigger scent that provokes
her into an uncontrollable blood rage
she can also heal from virtually any
injury that you're able to inflict on
her now
out the question becomes how do you kill
someone who can heal and regenerate from
seemingly any wound well we do have a
few possible answers to that question
that Marvel has provided us over the
years first there's the Muramasa blade
which I've gone over before a couple of
times both in my video on how to kill
Wolverine and Deadpool as well as my
video explaining Wolverines healing
factor so I'm not going to go super
in-depth into this because I some people
still want to rehash and bore the hell
out of you guys with that but the
Muramasa blade is a sword that was
forwards with part of Wolverine soul
inside and has the power to suppress
healing factors that we've seen it's
work when will reign decapitated and
killed Sabretooth so we know that the
blade is capable of negating mutant
healing factors in their entirety and so
using this we also know that if we were
able to use the blade to stab or
decapitate x-23 she's not going to be
able to heal herself
meaning that she's basically just going
to stay dead forever now speaking of
decapitation if that presents us with
another opportunity even if we don't
have the Muramasa blades while
Wolverines healing factor is extremely
potent and he can heal and regenerate
from some extremely traumatic injuries
one thing he cannot heal from is
decapitation and the reason that we
notice is that when Charles Xavier
develops his Xavier protocols which are
a set of contingencies to be inactive in
the event that any of the x-men become
threats to the earth security he
suggests decapitating Wolverine as a way
of elimination now it's important to
note that during this time Wolverine was
without his adamantium coated skeleton
as it occurred after magneto ripped the
adamantium from his skeleton and before
apocalypse took the adamantium they
coded saber-tooth skeleton and bonded it
to Wolverines
and so with adamantium in place on
Wolverine skeleton decapitation becomes
extremely difficult because you'd
effectively have to wedge the knife or
wedge the sword in between his vertebrae
in order to successfully pull it off
basically meaning that unless you're
like a surgeon going in to decapitate
Wolverine you're gonna have a very
difficult time trying to kill him that
way
and so what this does is make it
virtually indestructible to physical
harm now x-23 does not pose the same
challenge because only your claws not
her entire skeleton are coated with
adamantium that makes decapitating her a
whole lot easier although it's also
worth pointing out that part of the
Xavier protocol for killing Wolverine
was to decapitate him and then place his
head and his body apart from each other
so that made me something that we would
have to do with x-23 as well or maybe
Xavier is just suggesting that Wolverine
could heal from decapitation if it's
headed
body we're close enough together but we
don't really have a clear answer to that
now yet another way to kill x-23 exists
in the form of a substance called
carbonadium now carbonadium is a metal
that was created by the soviet
government when they were trying to
create their own version of adamantium
and what they got was an extremely
durable metal although not as durable as
adamantium but it's also malleable and
radioactive now because of its
radioactive qualities carbonadium is
able to slow down healing factors while
this provides us with a possible Avenue
for killing x-23 it's not guaranteed to
work the reason why is because Wolverine
and his son Dakin have both been shot
with bullets that were made from
carbonadium and it survived and their
healing factors returned to normal after
the bullets had been removed so this
might work but we would probably have to
use a lot of carbonadium in order to get
the job done now finally a surefire way
to kill x-23 would be to infect her with
the same virus that will drain was
infected with and that eventually led to
his death now i covered this in the
video on how Wolverines healing factor
works but this happens after Wolverines
healing factor is shut down by a virus
from the microburst which is basically a
super small universe inside the main
Marvel Universe but once that virus had
taken hold of Wolverine and run its
course he becomes completely killable
now given that x-23 scaling factor is an
exact copy of Logan it's pretty clear
that we could make x-23 killable by
giving her this exact same virus now
those are the best ways that I can think
of to kill x-23 although I'm sure that
it's not a very exhaustive list and
there are probably other ways to kill
her possibly drowning starvation or
something like that but those are pretty
boring ways so I decided not to include
them on this list I mean you know just
put X 23 in a cave and then just not
give her any food ah that would be
boring I mean I guess we could have
listed it you know just make her go sit
the cave and not have anybody to talk to
you and no food or water or anything I
mean I would have been boring but I am
curious to see what kind of ideas you
guys can come up with so if you guys
have any ideas on how to kill x-23 that
are not listed in this video then feel
free to post them down in the comment
section also the guys are new here to
the Rob Cork make sure you guys drop a
like and hit the subscribe button to
become part of the Rob core I guess if
you're new to the Rob core hit that sub
button become part cuz it's a subscriber
button do that and yeah I will catch you
all later please
[Music]